I know what this place is
the timekeepers have built quite the circus
and i see the clowns are playing
their parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you sound
super smart i am smart i know okay okay
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is absurd
sign this too
we protect the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality i want you to help us fix it
why me i need your unique loki
perspective do i get a weapon
you really believe in this loki variant luckily
he believes in himself enough for the both of us
It is adorable that you think
you could possibly manipulate me
i'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can trust me okay i've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people in the
back like 50 times why never do it again
Welcome back everyone it's charlie marvel just
dropped a brand new loki trailer with a whole
bunch of new easter eggs for the thor movies
the avengers movies so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel i'll be
doing videos for all the episodes so be sure
to subscribe to get everything we're doing a
giveaway for disney plus memberships too all you
have to do is enter is be a subscriber and just
leave your favorite easter egg from the trailer
so we'll just go through the shot by shot
and talk about easter eggs as we go along
but it looks like this is right after they capture
him with the tesseract like they're able to track
the tesseract or the other infinity stones as they
control the flow of time because the time variance
authority is all about sanctioning the official
timelines gardening the timeline so to speak if
you've seen rick and morty it's exactly like the
time police in also big coincidence too rick and
morty connection the showrunner for the loki
series also came from the rick and morty series
but this is obviously right after they capture
him with the tesseract and bring him back to
their facility outside of space time or outside of
normal space time within the mcu the way they talk
about the timeline being broken here they're just
talking about the main mcu timeline there are many
different sanctioned timelines that they have so
this is actually just one of them but the way they
talk about these alternate branch timelines those
become fully alternate realities with alternate
versions of all the characters but the whole idea
here is that this is a version of loki who never
went through the events of thor the dark world
he never had his redemption arc the last thing
that he remembers is getting thrashed by the hulk
and then captured by the avengers humiliated by
them so he is pissed off right now but as he says
during the trailer he actually does have knowledge
of the time variance authority he's aware of their
existence we can now see some of the signs all
over the walls here the doors just to explain
where all these different places are that they
visit during the trailer so this is the interior
of their archives with basically the entirety
of recorded history every single thing that's ever
happened to every single person like later in the
trailer when he's talking to the bureaucrat in
that little office where he says please verify
that these are all the things that you've ever
said in your entire life these three statues are
of the time keepers themselves they're the people
that founded the time variance authority because
the time variance authority mostly comes from the
thor in the fantastic four comics there's a big
theory that they're going to introduce the idea of
king the conqueror with easter eggs through this
series supporting this theory some websites are
reporting that Gugu Mbatha-Raw is playing ravana
renslayer the character from marvel comics who is
the love interest of king the conqueror so one of
the big theories going into ant-man 3 where we're
gonna see kang for the first time is that he was
at one time a time keeper because he is a master
of time he's a big time travel villain in the mcu
they take you on a bit of a tour of the time
variance authority through a lot of the different
floors as the camera spins around a little bit
like an hourglass there's an hourglass motif
built into a lot of the walls and the designs
of the building itself like look at the doors
of the elevator here it's all little carved
hourglasses you also probably noticed there
are clocks everywhere all over the place and a
lot of them actually denote different timelines
loki trying to sass his way out of the situation
the same way he did during the first avengers
movie because remember he's literally coming
from the events of that first avengers movie
so he just did the same thing to nick fury inside
that chamber for the hulk you notice owen wilson's
character in the background there he's actually
playing a character named mobius m mobius which
is obviously meant to be a palindrome even though
technically it's spelled wrong if it's going to
be a true palindrome but you get the joke it's
all just meant to be a play on the idea of time
i'm also getting a very hitchhiker's guide vibe
from a lot of these offices like a very british
sense of humor with the way the bureaucracy is
structured in here just humor around bureaucracy
let's create as many different lines and cues
we can like everyone to queue up to just stand
in line for another hour is almost like being a
comic-con these other people wearing the jumpsuits
obviously just other people that they've captured
because they've been messing with the timeline in
ways that they don't sanction the way they cut the
trailer is a little misleading this is actually
the scene where he cues up his life and he shows
him all the things that he just did during the
events of the avengers film this is them basically
reading him his rights like okay these are all the
things that you did that led up to you breaking
the timeline and this is why you have to fix it
i also love the little details that they work
into this too like they want to make this feel
as claustrophobic and alienating as possible like
it's not just loki that they're messing with here
they want to give anybody that sits in this room
an anxiety attack notice that the bureaucrat there
has a cat in the background who's just kind of
sitting there chilling out but he also has a mug
with his cat's picture on it too but we actually
get some really helpful information when they pull
this document out even though it's ridiculous
that he has to sign everything that he's ever
said they denote that he is loki variant number
l1130 meaning he is the 1130th version of loki
that should give you an idea for how long the
series could run that's why this is one of the
few series the marvel disney plusters that
they've already green lit for a season too
most of you could probably tell too the
whole idea with the shifting logo here
in all the letters in the background as it shifts
from loki green to marvel red you notice that all
the characters are just variants on different
fonts of loki's name it's just meant to denote
the many alternate versions of loki in all these
different time streams you get a better look at
some of their control rooms as he takes them in
and explains what's going on with the time stream
this is basically meant to denote the main mcu
time stream before the events of avengers infinity
war in avengers end game is that whole speech that
the ancient one gave to the hook like you take
this infinity stone and don't bring it back to
where you took it from and you doom this reality
that's why in a lot of these alternate timelines
where you see in the future you just see like the
earth burning in the background like the rubble
of the avengers tower in this version of earth
this version of president loki that seems like
he's ruling over some post-apocalyptic wasteland
they're just hyping up that everything goes to
complete crap in every one of these timelines
that loki has completely messed with because
he took the tesseract from that one reality
all the different monitors here with different
clocks and different a numbers are meant to
denote different time streams most of you probably
guess the twist here too when loki is asking owen
wilson's character why do you need me and he says
oh i need your unique loki perspective because
in all these branching timelines it's always loki
that's messing with things that leads to whatever
version of earth you are in these different
realities going to complete crap so it's
this loki going around hunting down all these
alternate loki's in all these branch timelines
so loki is both the main villain and the hero of
his own series then even though we don't spend a
whole lot of time in this first alternate reality
that he takes him to it's actually a wren fair you
see these people walking around in the background
in medieval looking clothing but this is probably
owen wilson's character just showing him the ropes
and of course the back of his jacket says variant
because he is a variant of the main version of
mcu loki remember the main mcu loki died during
avengers infinity war when this loki stole the
tesseract and created the branch timelines he
became an alternate reality loki that's why he's a
variant even if you're not a big comic book reader
you'll probably remember the name roxanne they
show up in a bunch of different marvel series
and in the movies just a little bit they're more
of a natural resources company but the way they're
playing this it's sort of like a roxanne version
of walmart that they're going to to take out
whatever this alternate version of loki has done
here this hooded figure though seems like it's
going to be female loki the way they're hyping
her up because she was also in the other trailer
footage taking out that other agent like you see
her take out these time variants authority agents
and then drag one through another portal or use
him to open another portal somewhere technically
speaking i don't know if she's meant to be the
main antagonist of the series but just the way
they're hyping her up and all the different
trailers they've released so far it seems
like she's one of the bigger versions of loki than
the others we've seen so far like there are many
loki's but some of them are bigger characters than
others during the series is this character here
where you see our alternate loki sitting down like
he's talking to her like they're just gonna have
a little chat two different versions of loki him
talking to the female version of himself cannot
wait to see what that's like more hourglasses and
more statues of the time keepers all over guggum
bathroom raw's office they're just using footage
like this to just play on the idea that he's going
to also continually try to pull a fast one on them
throughout the series really hard to tell what has
happened in this version of earth this looks like
some quarry or some post-apocalyptic wasteland
nightmare but this is the scene where you see him
talking to female loki we get a way better look at
the inside of the time variance authority and the
other buildings that make up their giant structure
then we see a version of loki in an alternate
reality version of asgard ruling on the throne
this seems like another alternate version of
the timeline where he pretended to be odin ruled
over asgard and then obviously you wind up with
ragnarok really hard to tell what's going on with
this structure too this could just be an alternate
version of asgard as well or some alternate place
it seems like it's going to be the layer of
female loki whichever layer she winds up coming
from because you see a version of what looks like
her fighting in this outfit here even though she's
spinning around so fast that you can't get a look
at her face it just seems like they're hyping this
up as dark as timeline loki like if we're talking
about rick and morty metaphors and easter eggs
think about evil morty to the other mortys the
really cool thing about this fight scene though is
you actually see him using a blast of green magic
that we haven't seen him used before in the mcu
so scarlet witch gets her power from chaos magic
that's why it's red doctor strange draws his magic
from another reality that's why it's a slightly
different color agatha harkness's magic is purple
because she actually takes magic from other people
to power herself up and they haven't explained too
much about where loki draws his magical energy
from so hopefully they'll get into more of his
character's history as well during the series
this very blade runner looking scene just seems
like them in the future of one of these alternate
timelines this is just the big db cooper scene
like they're trying to say that loki is a version
of db cooper in one of these realities the person
who was never foul they even have the easter
egg here of a couple dollar bills flying out as
he's grabbed by the bifrost like when he jumps
out of the back of the plane he says heimdall
brother talking to a version of thor whichever
reality is in here i hope you're ready as they
grab him mid-air if you're not familiar with
the story of db cooper he was a real figure who
robbed a bunch of banks but they never found his
body they only found some dollar bills this is
our main variant loki just fighting other time
variance authority cops i'm assuming this scene
is of him from a similar scene where he lands in
this post-apocalyptic wasteland and we're just
seeing the other side of the shot we're seeing his
reaction to everything like wait what happened to
new york city whatever he's done here whatever's
happening in the background with this giant
explosion it totally reminds me of that scene from
iron man 1 the very iconic iron man scene with him
raising his arms up as the dust envelops him but
like i said they have renewed it for season two
and obviously loki will show up during thor for
love and thunder at some point so that's sort
of the connection to the big marvel movies
but obviously i think some of this will also
set up what's happening during ant-man and the
wasp because king the conqueror big time travel
villain this is all about time travel in the mcu i
have done a couple thor 4 love and thunder videos
they've released some footage from the set so i'll
post links to that in the description below but if
you spotted any of the big easter eggs during the
trailer that i didn't talk about during the video
just write them below in the comments and leave
all your video requests in the comments below
while you wait for everything you can click here
for that brand new thor 4 love and thunder teaser
and that footage breakdown and you can click here
for my brand new falcon and winter soldier episode
4 trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!